m80 would know this we always hear of of
the lyrical spiritual miracle rappers
you've heard that term right
i feel like you are the quintessential
when we think of the lyrical spirit i
feel like i when when people say that i
think of cannabis right right
you have so many intricate ryan patters
[ __ ] the vocabulary is insane you're
[ __ ] i feel like sometimes i'll be
hearing you rapping it's like math
problems and all kinds of algorithmic
[ __ ] going on like
i feel like you you you are that guy
like
what do you like explain to me your
writing process so in the beginning it's
funny you say that because
in the beginning we were all lyrical
miracle guys right you know what i'm
saying but then
because that's what we'd get on we just
say look because you know he's saying
lyrical so you're looking at the next
words around with lyrical i'm saying
lyrical miracle spiritual individuals
and all that we were all that in the
beginning all of us were right and then
and then it got to the point where
some artists came out and they were more
you know to the to that the bling i'm
not i'm not singling out you know shout
out to cash money but i'm not singling
them out the bling bling the bling phase
because they started to bring error
right yeah so when the bling era came
and so much bread was being made from it
that you know
everybody started getting bread on that
side of things and then the lyrical
miracle dudes was just the backpackers
and the lyrical miracle dudes were broke
and they had nothing so then you found
dudes that were lyrical miracles you
know
laughing at other lyrical miracles wait
a minute there was a difference
yeah yeah and then and then and then and
then and then so one of my homies does
he doesn't say the lyrical miracle he's
with the fly die with the tie dye with
the mai tai yeah so so that's what
that's what it became and
you know it's kind of crazy when
you got your own you know dudes cut from
the same cloth you know rhyme ability
wise laughing at the lyrical miracles so
then because you know the machine helped
them get the bread
you can't get the bread and then certain
things started happening so
yeah man i mean
you know i was happy to graduate out of
the lyrical miracle phase because it was
a phase we all go through
then i got into the poetry and i did
that probably circle right what i say
right for whom to be toes oh seven
that's when it got to where
the rhymes that were coming out of my
mouth
no one could shadow them would you
didn't know what i was going to say next
because
you know lyrical wasn't going to rhyme
with miracle
i was going to make lyrical rhyme with
molybdenum